einen schönen guten abend wir sind live
mit zdf heute live seit heute geht es
ans eingemachte denn spd grüne und fdp
haben ihre koalitionsverhandlungen
gestartet und der zeitplan für die
bildung einer neuen regierung ist
absolut optimistisch um nikolaus herum
also anfang dezember soll olaf scholz
schon zum neuen bundeskanzler einer
ersten ampelkoalition auf bundesebene
wäre das gewählt werden so weit so schön
aber so ein paar punkte gilt es ja
vorher doch noch zu klären und vor allem
die frage woher denn das geld für diese
ehrgeizigen pläne kommen soll wir offen
erhoffen uns antworten heute abend von
juso chefin jessica rosenthal und von
jens trine bundesvorsitzender der jungen
liberalen einen schönen guten abend
ihnen beiden
guten abend wir wollen gleich mit ihnen
sprechen geben sie uns vorher noch zwei
minuten der mit loves bohnsack uns auf
den neuesten stand bringen kann wie es
denn heute gelaufen
die äußeren umstände am verhandlungsort
waren heute eher widrig drinnen aber
verbreiten spd grüne und fdp optimismus
und überraschen mit einem ambitionierten
zeitplan die koalitionsverhandlungen
sollen deutlich früher als bisher
geplant beendet werden weil wir sehr
ehrgeizig sind und ende des monats
november ein vertragswerk auch vorliegen
haben wollen dass es uns ermöglicht in
der woche vom 6 dezember einen
bundeskanzler für die bundesrepublik
deutschland zu wählen und eine
bundesregierung zu bilden ein straffer
zeitplan also für die 22
verhandlungsgruppen die zudem weder an
den wochenenden noch bis tief in die
nacht arbeiten sollen sie tragen die
volle verantwortung für die ergebnisse
die arbeitsgruppen haben den klaren
auftrag bekommen dass konflikte dort
geklärt werden sollen also man kennt das
ja aus anderen verhandlungen auch dass
es dann am ende schloss papiere von
arbeitsgruppen gibt wo 20.30 klammern
drin sind die dann in der
hauptverhandlung runde geklärt werden
sollen da haben wir explizit gesagt es
soll in den arbeitsgruppen sollen
konflikte geklärt werden an den
beschlüssen die bereits im sondierungs
papier festgehalten sind soll in den
koalitionsverhandlungen nicht mehr
gerüttelt werden dort geht es dann aber
um die wirklichen knackpunkte wie zum
beispiel die steuer und finanzpolitik
ist auch nicht die aufgabe von
sondierungen zu allen fachlichen themen
schon lösungen zu präsentieren sondern
dass es aufgabe dann der
koalitionsverhandlungen und der
arbeitsgruppen dafür lösung zu finden
und auch themen zu diskutieren
kommenden mittwoch beginnen die
verhandlungsgruppen mit ihrer arbeit zu
tun gibt es noch reichlich
classica rosenthal und jens todt trainer
sind heute abend vor allem darum zu
ihren fragen antworten zu geben oder zu
ihren kommentaren stellung zu beziehen
deshalb bitte einfach in die kommentare
spalten reinschreiben oder an die
adresse schicken die sie jetzt
hoffentlich eingeblendet sehen da ist
sie frau rosenthal sie waren heute
morgen ja schon bei unserem zdf mona und
da haben sie gesagt sie finden das gut
wenn eine neue regierung bis weihnachten
stehen würde jetzt soll sogar von
nikolaus werden wie realistisch bewerten
sie diesen zeitplan
also ich muss sagen ich teile den
optimismus total den auch heute die
parteispitzen verkündet haben ich finde
es ist ein straffer zeitplan aber wir
haben ja auch gesehen und ich hoffe dass
das wirklich auch bildend ist für die
politische kultur die wir haben dass man
eben sehr diszipliniert verhandeln kann
auch vertraulich und das ist natürlich
jetzt auch vorbild für die weiteren
koalitionsverhandlungen
und ich zumindest für meinen teil bin
fest entschlossen genau diese
erwartungen jetzt auch zu erfüllen das
land hat so viel vor sich und da müssen
wir so schnell es geht auch anfangen
also ich finde das genau richtig so wie
es vor gestellt ist und freue mich
darauf dass jetzt auch einzuhalten
also großer optimismus bei den jusos
hertha-trainer wie ist das bei ihnen
nach ihren erfahrungen bei
koalitionsverhandlungen mit der fdp
müssten sie jetzt eigentlich zittern bis
zum schluss ich muss nicht zittern bis
zum schluss in nordrhein westfalen haben
wir aber ich begleitet als
landesvorsitzender jungen liberalen die
verhandlungen zu einer schwarz gelben
landesregierung
da mussten wir auch nicht getan es gibt
zwar kein ampel automatismus ich finde
es aber gut dass wir im politischen stil
uns auch hier vorbild nehmen das dann
beispielsweise die arbeitsgruppe
einzelne kompromisse schließen dass wir
nicht zu lange vorhanden und ich glaube
das war ein großes problem letztes mal
bei jamaika da wurde ja nicht mal 20 mit
der beginn von koalitionsverhandlungen
soll man hat so ewige sondierungen
geführt wo immer die unterschiede betont
wurden und das betont wurde was ein
getrennt und jetzt soll das c sein
gemeinsamkeiten und kompromisse zu
finden das ist ein schneller in einer
schnellen takt da jetzt schon eine
grundlage auch gelegt wurde und deswegen
bin ich sehr optimistisch dass wir das
auch positiv begleiten werden
ihre parteien haben zusammen mit den
grünen ja schon ein sanierungspaket
erarbeitet in dem auch tatsächlich schon
einiges drin steht und die wichtigsten
punkte hat meine kollegin fahrer schlink
nochmal zusammengefasst
koalieren geht über finanzieren so
scheint es bei den ampel partnern
geradezu heißen doch wer soll am ende
alles bezahlen nach einer vom
bundesverband der deutschen industrie
vorgelegten studie sind in deutschland
investitionen von 860 milliarden euro
notwendig alleine um die klimaziele für
das jahr 2030 zu ärgern im ampel
sondierung papier kommen zudem viele
weitere wunschprojekte dazu die
modernisierung der infrastruktur zum
beispiel dafür seien wohl investitionen
von rund 50 milliarden euro pro jahr
notwendig über gesellschaften sollen
diese gestemmt werden wie das genau
aussehen soll ist noch unklar die
schuldenbremse jedenfalls solle nicht
aufgeweicht werden fest versprochen sei
auch keine neuen substanz steuern und
steuern die einkommen unternehmens und
mehrwertsteuer nicht zu erhöhen auch
nicht für das notwendige geld um den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst sowie das
bildungswesen zu digitalisieren
oder das vorhaben mehr bezahlten
wohnraum zu schaffen ziel sei der bau
von 400.000 neuen wohnungen pro jahr
davon 100.000 öffentlich geförderte
wohnungen
überhaupt soll überall gefördert
gestärkt und entlastet werden die
forschung und die landwirtschaft sollen
demnach auch nicht zu kurz kommen wie
aber geht diese rechnung auf die ampel
steht auf grün für ein jahrzehnt der
zukunftsinvestitionen
finanzierung unklar
ja die frage gebe ich gerne an sie beide
weiter wer soll das bezahlen
frau rosenthal vielleicht rasieren
naja ich hab ja in der vergangenheit
oder den vergangenen tagen schon
deutlich gemacht dass ich es natürlich
sehr schade finde dass die vorschläge
die wir gemacht haben als spd nämlich
die mit mittleren und unteren einkommen
zu entlasten und dafür in der spitze
eben eine andere verteilung auch möglich
zu machen dass die nicht sich im
regierungs papier wiederfinden wir haben
auch eine vermögenssteuer vorgeschlagen
das ist jetzt nicht drin in dieser
koalition ich glaube damit muss man
jetzt auch umgehen damit muss man auch
leben und deshalb stellt sich genau die
frage wie soll man stattdessen machen
ich möchte da aber vor allem den blick
noch mal darauf lenken was kostet es uns
eigentlich wenn wir das nicht tun und
ich glaube gerade in dieser pandemie
haben wir haben wir diese auswirkungen
sehr krass gesehen also wenn ich kein
home office machen kann oder auch keinen
homeschooling habe ich auch erlebt bei
meinen schülerinnen und schülern dann
kann ich mich lernen dann kann ich nicht
arbeiten und das schadet unserem
wirtschaftsstandort haben wir noch gar
nicht darüber gesprochen was es bedeutet
wenn wir in der technologie nicht
wirklich ja richtig weitermachen auch
forschen entwickeln innovationen fördern
wenn wir nicht die energie am ende haben
mit der dann auch industrie bezahlbar
produzieren kann das sind alles sachen
die wir uns aus meiner sicht nicht
leisten können von daher geht es um
diese zukunftsinvestition die stehen
also nicht zur debatte sondern die frage
wie man es finanziert und die ist auch
für mich weiterhin offen
ok am herd trainer frau rosenthal
bedauert dass es keine vermögenssteuer
gibt und eben dieses thema umverteilung
so nicht kommen wird sie müssten das
doch feiern wir haben dafür im wahlkampf
geworben das hat auch seine gründe wenn
man über vermögenssteuer spricht dann
hört sich das immer so an wie da haben
ganz viele leute irgendwie geld auf
bankkonten herumliegen und das müssen
wir den jetzt mal weg nehmen und dann
kann der staat mal ordentlich
investieren die realität ist bei einer
vermögenssteuer eine andere vermögen
sind die gebäude die substanz der
unternehmen anlagen maschinen also das
ist gebundenes kapital und wir haben in
der korona pandemie unternehmen mit
unternehmenshilfen gerettet und zu
glauben wenn wir jetzt die unternehmen
mit einer vermögenssteuer und die
substanz besteuern belasten dann würden
wir am ende mehr steuereinnahmen haben
ist falsch denn bevor wir überhaupt
steuereinnahmen kriegen muss überhaupt
etwas erwirtschaftet werden und deswegen
ist es nach einer wirtschaftlichen krise
ein wichtiges signal dass die
unternehmen nicht noch mehr belastet
werden und deswegen finde ich diese
absage auch korrekt und richtig dass wir
das so festgehalten haben und es gibt ja
kein bekenntnis zu schwarzen null
sondern zur schuldenbremse in der ist es
durchaus möglich auch für investitionen
geld zum beispiel über kredite
aufzunehmen und ihn und sicherlich
müssen wir uns über die finanzierung
jetzt auch noch mal sprechen in den
verhandlungen ein sanierungspaket kein
haushaltsplan ich habe aber vielleicht
etwas mehr vertrauen als jessica den
finanzminister urlaub scheut der kennt
seinen haushalt sehr sehr gut und er
weiß glaube ich schon was dort möglich
ist und was nicht möglich ist war frau
großen teil da muss ich sie direkt
fragen vertrauen sie urlaub falls nicht
ich vertraue olaf scholz 100 prozentig
und ich freue mich sehr dass er der
zukünftige kanzler unseres landes wird
mir geht es dabei also weniger darum was
hat der finanzminister bis hierher getan
oder scholz wird der kanzler und nicht
finanzminister sondern was machen wir in
zukunft und da muss ich einfach sagen es
die mehr zu sagen die vermögen wachsen
ja gar nicht und das ist irgendwie nun
unternehmens frage das ist einfach
falsch wir sehen dass die hälfte der
bevölkerung kein vermögen hat und wir
sehen vor allem dass in der zeit meiner
lebensspanne die privaten investitionen
massivst zurückgegangen sind dh den
investitionsstau den wir haben haben wir
auch auf privater seite das hat viele
gründe das hat sicherlich auch den grund
dass politik gerade in den letzten
jahren eigentlich sicht gescheitert
davon nur zur weichenstellung
vorzunehmen das können wir jetzt anders
machen das können wir jetzt besser
machen beispielsweise wenn wir sagen ja
wir wollen elektromobilität und das ist
jetzt auch die weichenstellung die wir
gehen wir wollen erneuerbare energien da
gibt es jetzt klare bekenntnisse die
auch das regierungspapier schon liefert
und das ist dann glaube ich auch das was
wir mit aufbruch meint was wir mit
fortschritt meinen und da kann ich dann
auch wieder eine gemeinsamkeit mit jens
herstellen weil ich glaube das meinen
wir dann beide und da können wir glaube
ich dann auch unternehmen und den staat
beide zusammen darf dazu begeistern auch
zu investieren jetzt muss man ja sagen
deutsche top ökonomen loben das
sondierungs papier ja im großen und
ganzen aber auch denen es noch nicht so
ganz klar wie das ganze finanziert
werden soll wir hören mal kurz rein was
diw-chef vater dazu denkt also use ist
das nicht weil das ist gar nicht machbar
dieser spagat sehr viel mehr geld
ausgeben zu wollen 50 60 milliarden euro
mehr pro jahr
gleichzeitig keine mehreinnahmen also
sprich keine zusätzlichen steuern und
man will auch nur die schuldenbremse
einhalten die man schon ohne die
mehrausgaben verfehlen würde dieser
spagat ist gar nicht möglich und da muss
man sich ehrlich machen und sagen wie
will man das leisten ich glaube wichtig
ist eine prioritätensetzung wo wie man
die oberste priorität gegen will man
sagen auf jeden fall schulden abbauen
oder will man sagen zukunftsinvestition
das ist das wichtigste und das muss eine
koalition oder eine vermeintliche
produktion jetzt ganz dringend als
erstes klären
und forscher plädiert jetzt dafür
kurzfristig mehr schulden aufzunehmen
und zu mal die schuldenbremse ja auch im
kommenden jahr noch ausgesetzt ist aber
da heißt es ja auch das kann nicht der
weg sein was wäre denn dann der weg der
hertha trainer ja ich habe mich könnten
politischen vorschlag auch präsentieren
wir haben noch sehr viele aktien anteile
zum beispiel an der post oder der
telekom das sind 40 milliarden euro die
der staat der besitz die könnten wir
veräußern und direkt investieren und was
man auch berücksichtigen muss die
meisten investitionen passieren gar
nicht auf staatliche hand sondern prix
aus privater hand das verhältnis 1 zu 9
und deswegen ist es so wichtig und damit
fängt das sondierungs papier an das land
auch zu entfesseln wir wollen die
genehmigungsverfahren auch die hälfte
reduzieren damit es attraktiver ist
investieren es braucht
planungssicherheit bringen die reise
hingeht da gibt es einen weg also wie
man private mitte auch
los machen kann damit in zukunft dort
mehr investiert wird und deswegen gibt
es dann ja auch wachstum und es gibt
ganz viel eine abschreibung
sonderprogramm sofortprogramm wird das
genannt um wachstumsimpulse zu setzen um
dann auch in den späteren
haushaltsjahren wieder mehr einnahmen zu
generieren
ich habe eine frage an sie auf youtube
da müssen wir aber versprechen dass sie
die so erklären dass es auch jeder
versteht wie gewichtet die fdp das thema
der steuerfreien veräußerung der gewinne
aus wertpapieren nach langer haltedauer
das wäre ein großer schritt für die
stärkung der privaten altersvorsorge
ich habe das selbst nach dem ergebnis
der sondern sondierungs papieren als
eine forderung die die die wir junge
liberale noch an die an das
koalitionsgespräch
genannt da geht es um die sogenannte
spekulationsfrist also wenn jemand eine
gewisse haltedauer hat bei aktien
wertpapieren oder ähnliches dass er dann
nicht noch einmal steuern darauf zahlen
muss beispielsweise bei immobilien gibt
es da schon wenn man das zehn jahre hält
da geht es dann nicht um spekulanten die
kurzfristig irgendwie gewinne generieren
wollen sondern geht es um altersvorsorge
private vorsorge und ich finde wenn sie
über vermögensungleichheit entsprechend
sprechen wir doch auch darüber wie wir
die vielen kleinen einkommen und
mittleren einkommen dazu befähigen sich
auch vermögen aufzubauen und deswegen
ist das für mich ein wichtiger punkt und
eine säule auch und ich würde mich sehr
freuen wenn die anderen parteien bereits
und da ein kompromiss zu finden frau
rosenthal ich habe hier noch einen
kommentar zu dem sie bitte was sagen
können
da schreibt ein user ich halte das für
finanzierbar vermögenssteuer gab es
schon mal hat kein geld eingebracht
kosten der verwaltung waren genauso hoch
wie die einnahmen weniger steuern führen
zu mehr steuereinnahmen
also für mich ist in jedem fall ganz
klar dass es die dass die
vermögenssteuern eine wichtige frage
gewesen wäre auch eine wichtige frage
die einkommen durchaus generieren kann
das kommt ja auch darauf an wie man das
macht es geht dabei auch um umverteilung
und da möchte ich schon gerne auch mit
einer mär aufräumen wenn wir schon über
altersvorsorge sprechen was jetzt ja
auch angeklungen ist dass man einfach
privat vorsorgen kann die hälfte der
bevölkerung und übrigens bei den unter
35-jährigen das ist noch eklatanter die
ungleichheit die wir vorfinden kann
nicht privat vorsorgen ich bin voll
dabei zusagen mittlere und untere
einkommen müssen vermögen aufbauen
können ja genau darum geht es deswegen
brauchen wir mindestlohn deswegen müssen
wir den niedriglohnsektor bekämpfen
deswegen reden wir auch darüber dass wir
zum beispiel arbeitsplätze brauchen die
gut bezahlt sind und nicht befristet
sind das sind alles punkte die dann ja
am besten fall auch dazu führen aber es
geht eben nicht darum zu sagen die
obersten prozent das sind jetzt die die
wir entlasten müssen da läuft schon also
das ist einfach ne mehr nur wie gesagt
ich gucke jetzt nicht zurück ich arbeite
mit dem sanierungs papier was wir haben
das sind auch gute umverteilungs aspekte
drin wir wollen dass gerade mittlere und
untere einkommen besser klar kommen dass
nicht die lebenshaltungskosten die
mietkosten die immer steige immer weiter
steigen irgendwie ein über den kopf
wachsen man das gefühl hat klimawandel
können jetzt nicht auch noch machen das
geht nicht und deswegen sind da schon
gute punkte drin aber mir geht es ganz
klar auch darum noch mehr soziale
gerechtigkeit da rein zu verhandeln und
dann bin ich nicht bei der veräußerung
von post aktien oder telekom-aktien im
gegenteil da werde ich mich massiv gegen
während weil ich schon glaube dass wir
da sein vor so wenn der staat in der
hand des staates brauchen aber wie
gesagt da werden sicherlich noch
diskutieren und das sieht man vielleicht
auch es gibt auf jeden fall auch
diskussionsbedarf trotzdem bleibt ja die
frage woher dieses ganze geld für diese
ehrgeizigen pläne ja kommen soll denn
das heißt soll keine neuen steuern geben
die schuldenbremse soll ja aber auch
nicht aufgeweicht werden und dann ist
zum beispiel die rede davon dass im
bundeshaushalt noch spielraum wäre war
es ja bisher zum beispiel für schulen
oder einrichtungen dieser art auch nicht
woher soll denn jetzt das geld kommen
na ja also wir haben ja schon einige
vorschläge wenn ich vielleicht da
einfach mal den anfang machen die auf
dem tisch jetzt sind und wenn wir sagen
und das sagt die koalition ja jetzt
schon im sommer jungs papier es geht um
zukunftsinvestitionen dann heißt das
eben auch dass wir gerade die investiven
kosten die wir haben und da wird es
nicht nur private geben ich geb dir
vollkommen recht jens das ist auch
private braucht und gerade auch private
die wir befähigen müssen jetzt und dann
finde ich diese richtungsentscheidungen
die ich schon angesprochen habe wichtig
dass sie investieren aber wir brauchen
auch staatlich und das steht glaube ich
außer frage ich glaube wo ich mir auch
ein ich bin mit der fdp und auch mit
euch als julis das ist die frage wie
macht man dann solche investitionen wir
sehen ja zum beispiel dass noch große
töpfe gerade im bildungsbereich
eigentlich fast gar nicht ausgegeben
sind und da sind dann ja durchaus noch
spielräume und da frage ich mich dann
aber geht es uns jetzt auf bundesebene
darum einfach einen topf zu schaffen und
nicht dafür zu sorgen dass das geld vor
ort ankommen das sind schultoiletten
keiner sich hin traut weil man die
einfach nicht benutzen kann keiner
irgendwie eine digitalisierte schule
vorgefunden haben aber wie auf
bundesebene sagen hier da gibt es doch
einen topf also wenn ich über förderung
sprechen wenn ich auch über staatliche
aufgaben sprechen wo wir viel mehr
machen müssen dann sollte es darum gehen
dass das geld auch abfließt und haben
wir gerade bei der frage bildung echt
noch viel zu tun
außerdem heißt es ja im sondierungs
papier das
die mögliche neue regierung auf
zusatzeinnahmen setzen würde zum
beispiel heißt es geld aus
steuervermeidung oder sie rechnen mit
milliarden einnahmen aus einer geplanten
globalen mindestbesteuerung von panzern
die angedacht ist aber auch noch nicht
konkret
dann weisst ja jetzt eigentlich keiner
wie viel da jetzt zusammen kommt ist das
nicht so ein bisschen vage für eine
solide finanzierungsgrundlage also ein
baukredit würden sie so nicht bekommen
hat verträgen ja ich wollte das noch mal
auch betonen was auch jessica gerade
schon gesagt hat wir haben ja um das
konkret man machen es gab ja diesen
sogenannten digital packt wo dann die
schulen mittel vom bund bekommen haben
um die digitalisierung investieren also
kann man davon ist nur ein bruchteil der
mittel abgeflossen also der staat ist
viel viel zu bürokratisch auch an vielen
stellen und deswegen stimmlich da
vollkommen zu dass wir da am besten
sogar noch einen digital pack 2.0 2.0
brauchen deren wissen besser abfließt
aber auch um ihre frage zu beantworten
ein mittel ist und das ist ganz fest
dort auch eine verankert in den
sondierungsrunden
abschreibungs sofortprogramm was wir da
wollen das führt nämlich dann schon
mittelfristig dafür für die nächsten
haushaltsjahre dazu dass es insgesamt
mehr steuereinnahmen gibt ohne dass man
gleich immer steuern erhöhen muss weil
das kann durchaus die negative effekt
haben dass am ende gar nicht mehr
eingenommen wird ich habe einen
vorschlag gemacht wie wir beispielsweise
40 milliarden euro investieren könnten
durch die telekom anteile und die
post-anteile ich glaube der staat ist
nicht der bessere unternehmer der sollte
die nicht halten ich guck mal in den
koalitionsverhandlungen ab dass alle so
konsequent ablehnen wie jessica ich
würde mich dann aber auch immer freuen
wenn gegenvorschlag beispielsweise kommt
und ich glaube das wäre schon gute
mutter mittel um nachher mehr zu
investieren ok dann wollen wir mal
dieses finanzierungs thema dabei
beschließen es ist halt einfach noch
nicht klar und noch nicht beschlossen
das müssen wir fairerweise auch
konstatieren frau rosenthal ich habe
eine frage an sie von franka sie
schreibt auf facebook ist eine
bildungsreform geplant ein modernes
gerechteres bildungssystem
sie sitzen ja in der entsprechenden
arbeitsgruppe was können sie uns
berichten
genau also es ist nicht so dass ich in
bildung weiter verhandelt sondern es gab
dann auch meine änderung so dass ich
jetzt den bereich arbeit und ausbildung
verhandeln kann trotzdem kann ich
natürlich sagen was meine
erwartungshaltung und auch die dinge
sind für die wir als spd ein stehen und
wo ich aber auch sehr und das muss ich
wirklich sagen dass sondierungs papier
ist im bildungsbereich stark jens ich
weiß nicht wie du das beurteilt aber ich
fühle mich echt gefreut als ich das
gelesen habe da geht es nämlich genau
darum noch weiter zu investieren da geht
es vor allem um langfristige
finanzierungen ich kann das nur sagen
wenn man immer wieder sagt jetzt machen
wir mal plötzlich was und dann stehen
die kommunen da hatten gar nicht die
personalkapazitäten um zu planen die
schulen sowieso nicht immer noch mehr
bürokratische hürden um das geld
überhaupt zu bekommen das funktioniert
nicht und deshalb ist diese langfristige
finanzierung wirklich stark und ich
glaube dass wir da schon der bildungs
revolution ziemlich nahe kommen ich kann
natürlich als juso vorsitzende sagen
wenn ich von bildungs revolution spreche
dann kann ich mir auch viel stärker
vorstellen demokratisierung von schulen
auch auf bundesebene debatte darüber was
der schule leisten wie können
schülerinnen und schüler mit bestimmen
also daher kann ich mir immer noch mehr
vorstellen aber von der
finanzierungsfrage und von dem wie auch
der bund verantwortung übernimmt war ich
schon sehr begeistert als ich das
sondierungs papier gelesen habe und bin
auch sehr optimistisch was die
koalitionsverhandlungen angeht ich
möchte mal noch mal auf das große thema
klimaschutz eingehen also die solardach
pflicht für gewerbliche neubauten soll
kommen der kohleausstieg heißt es soll
bis 2030 idealer weise gelingen ihre
kolleginnen und kollegen von der grünen
jugend sagen das reicht alles nicht und
auch freddys for future ist absolut
nicht zufrieden da hören wir mal kurz
rein
wenn der kohleausstieg bis 2030 nur
idealer weise durchgeführt werden soll
dann reicht es eben nicht das ist unsere
zukunft und idealerweise eine zukunft zu
haben dass es eben nicht was wir
brauchen dieses papier entspricht eben
auch nicht den erwartungen die karlsruhe
eigentlich an die neue regierung auch
gestellt hat die ist eben ganz klar und
zwar eben mehr zu machen und unsere
beziehung zu entlassen
frau rosenthal sehen sie ihre generation
entlastet ich glaube auf jeden fall dass
da die richtigen schritte eingeschlagen
werden also wenn ich da wenn ich mir
gerade diese punkte die sie auch
angesprochen haben anschaue dann ist das
glaube ich schon mehr als wir jetzt in
den letzten jahren gesehen haben ich
verstehe auch total dass man sagt das
reicht immer noch nicht gleichzeitig
sehe ich aber natürlich auch dass wir
gerade beim ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien unter teile ich die frustration
von allen jungen menschen überhaupt
verschlafen haben und jetzt ist viel zu
wenig voran geht und deswegen müssen wir
eine energieversorgung des landes
sicherstellen und gleichzeitig gucken
dass wir da endlich vorankommen ich
glaube da sind diese fragen von
genehmigungsverfahren
die punkte von ausbauzielen extrem
wichtig da das ist was was die diese
regierung sofort anpacken muss und
sofort angehen muss damit wir eben aus
der kohle auch früher aussteigen können
das ist auch ein ziel was ich habe und
was wir erreichen wollen und müssen nur
wir müssen gleichzeitig eben auch die
auf die frage von energieversorgung
schauen und da sind schwarze finden ist
superschwer es geht in die richtige
richtung und ich hoffe dass wir im
politischen handeln dann noch tempo rein
bringen können
hertha-trainer wie steht es denn da um
ihre partei ihr parteikollege hat
gestern etwas getwittert das schauen wir
uns mal kurz an vielleicht können wir
den feed mal kurz zeigen
da sehen wir es wir könnten einfach
einen satz mit alles wird morgen
abgestellt da rein schreiben und ihr
würdet trotzdem diese aktion machen aber
die vermutung da geht es mittlerweile
weniger ums klima als ums ego also da
ging es um die forderung von fridays for
future die ihr kollege kritisiert wie
hilfreich sind solche äußerungen während
der verhandlung ja wir reden sehr sehr
viel über ziele und wir könnten jetzt da
rein schreiben noch mal fünf jahre
früher aussteigen und wir haben auch im
wahlkampf sehr viel über ziele geräte
und das ist auch gut dass wir uns da am
pariser klimaabkommen orientieren nur
wir müssen auch nicht nur über ziele
sprechen wir müssen diese ziele auch
wirklich erreichen wir haben die pariser
knapp kommunizieren und die werden ja
verfehlt und das ist ja die kritik und
deswegen finde ich das auch richtig dass
man erst mal auch darüber über den weg
zum beispiel diskutiert also
genehmigungsverfahren beschleunigen für
die erneuerbare energie und ich möchte
etwas noch grundsätzlich zu diesem klima
politischen diskurs beitragen ich finde
es richtig dass sich die koalition klar
zur sozialen ökologischen
marktwirtschaft betonung liegt auf
marktwirtschaft
verständigt hat weil kein land dieser
welt wird deutschland folgen nur weil
wir sehr gut verzicht üben die
industrialisierung und arbeitsplätze
gefährden wir haben jetzt schon die
höchsten strompreise dieser welt die
anderen länder dieser welt werden uns
nur folgen wenn wir beweisen man kann
wohlstand und klimaschutz
marktwirtschaft und klimaschutz und das
alles auch bezahlbaren deswegen glaube
ich helfen nicht immer vom rand nur die
kommentare zu machen sondern ich bin
sehr froh dass wir da glaube ich eine
gute mischung aus ökologie und ökonomie
gefunden haben sicherlich muss da jetzt
einiges an politischer lyriker nochmal
ausdifferenziert werde finde aber auch
da hat der max mordhorst sehr provokant
formuliert aber durch einen durchaus
einen punkt dass ich manchmal das gefühl
habe es ist eigentlich egal was die
politik der macht am ende ist frei dafür
future unzufrieden weil in wahrheit
wollen sie eines streams change und die
marktwirtschaft überwinden das lassen
wir mal so stehen und gehen aber nochmal
auf ein thema einen dass unsere
userinnen und user im netz wahnsinnig
interessiert nämlich die frage wie sieht
es mit der cannabis legalisierung aus
ich würde sagen gut ich
glaube da gibt es eine große einigkeit
es ist mir eine fachliche frage haben
die spd die die haut manchmal noch ein
bisschen und wir eine
entkriminalisierung aber wenn jessica
auch sagt sie glaubt dass sie gut aus
dann gibt es dort glaube ich auch eine
einigung jetzt geht es ein bisschen um
die umsetzung frage ich finde es auch
ehrlicherweise richtig dass es noch
nicht im sondierungs papier vereinbart
wurde da wohnen die ganz großen
gesellschaftlichen linien auf vereinbart
ich bin selbst ein glühender anhänger
für die legalisierung von cannabis war
auf noble mariana märschen auf messen
und setzen sich für dieses thema an aber
es ist dann glaube ich schon richtig
dass im koalitionsvertrag
anzusiedeln und am ende gibt es da ja
auch darum mit welchem modell machen
will dass wir favorisieren die
lizensierten fachgeschäfte bei die
qualitätsstandards schaffen weil sie
jugendschutz gewährleisten und weil sie
die chance haben auch den schwarzmarkt
entgegenzutreten das sehen die grünen
eine sehr sehr ähnlich und deswegen bin
ich optimistisch dass das am ende des
koalitionsvertrag drin sein muss auch
wenn wir am ende mehr als eine
ampelkoalition sein da steht jetzt nur
ein bisschen kiffen freigibt ist ein
wichtiger punkt
den unterstreichen alle
jugendorganisationen gemeinsam es gibt
aber auch noch andere gute punkte die
wir noch verhandeln lassen ja das sehe
ich vielleicht um das nur noch kurze zu
ergänzen ganz genau so wir haben dafür
ja auch innerhalb der spd
überzeugungsarbeit geleistet als jusos
auch über viele jahre hinweg und wir
sind ganz froh dass da auch die spd und
unsere spd verantwortlichen sich haben
überzeugen das sind von daher stehen an
der stelle glaube ich die ampeln auf
grün
frau rosenthal lassen uns zum schluss
vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz übers
personal reden keine angst es geht nicht
um namen aber es geht darum was die spd
möchte die möchte nämlich die posten
paritätisch besetzen also gleichmäßig
mit männern und frauen und fdp viel zu
kubicki sagt das ist quatsch er möchte
dass die qualifikation ausschlaggebend
ist wie kommen sie da zusammen das kann
ich ihnen nicht sagen und ich sage ihnen
auch ganz klar dass das für mich zu
diesem zeitpunkt keine rolle spielt weil
ich über die inhalte sprechen möchte und
wir erstmal über die inhalte überhaupt
klar werden müssen bevor es um personal
geht da bin ich auch ein bisschen vor
geprägt von der großen koalition wo auch
immer ganz ganz viel personal geredet
wurde und ganz wenig dann über
sachthemen vor allem seitens der union
ich habe das gefühl das wird jetzt hier
anders das sind alles drei parteien die
total für inhalte brennen ganz
unterschiedlich glaube man hat schon
heute gesehen denn so dick wird auch
nicht immer einer meinung aber auf jeden
fall die sachthemen nach vorne stellen
da würde ich gerne bleiben trotzdem sage
ich aber auch und das ist für mich mehr
als nur personalfragen dass es natürlich
eine repräsentanz von frauen braucht und
ich sage das auch als junge politikerin
es ist für uns wichtig auch zu sehen was
wir für starke menschen und starke
frauen in der politik haben und ich
finde dass das auch auf jeden fall drin
sein muss aber wie gesagt das steht ganz
am ende von den gesprächen die ja jetzt
gerade erst starten okay machen wir
vielleicht zum schluss noch eine kleine
schlussrunde ich möchte sie bitten den
folgenden satz zu vervollständigen
härter trainiert damit es mit der ampel
bis dezember klappt muss die spd muss
die spd sowie die grünen und die fdp bei
den neuen politischen stil festhalten so
wie jetzt kann ich das gemacht haben wir
streiten inhaltlichen einigen punkten
besuchen am ende gemeinsamkeiten es gibt
vertrauensvolle gespräche und wir suchen
das gemeinsame und das ziel ist ein
aufruf für unser land frozen teilt damit
es mit der ampel bis dezember klappt
muss die fdp
genau auch an diesem stil weiter
festhalten und vor allem die jungen
menschen nicht aus dem blick verlieren
weil auch da sind jens und ich uns sehr
einig die brauchen eine stimme die sind
zu wenig gehört worden und das müssen
wir ändern und dafür sind wir beide hier
mit vielen auch von der grünen jugend
und da freue ich mich auch auf eine
parlamentarische arbeit die sich
vielleicht ein stück weit verändern wird
also was wir heute abend glaube ich
festhalten können ist dass man bei jusos
und ju ließ schon ein sehr konstruktives
und harmonisches miteinander führt ich
danke ihnen beiden für das gespräch und
wünsche ihnen gutes gelingen bei den
weiteren verhandlungen ist gut das
dankeschön schießt ja und auch in vielen
dank für die fragen kommentare und fürst
dabei sein ein schöner abend noch bis
bald